dans les années 2000 la région centre
connaît la plus grande crise de
l'industrie automobile depuis l'après
guerre
on peut concevoir effectivement qui est
née lambdas d'activité l'impact était
réelle ou on a vu une baisse phénoménal
c'est depuis octobre aujourd'hui on est
on n'est pas sûr de l'avenir de tous les
équipementiers automobiles les ventes de
voitures s'effondrent les sous traitants
malheureusement dans le monde ouvrier
les salariés eux ils ont pâti sts
chômage partiel imposés licenciements
fermetures d'entreprises le bilan social
est lourd un emploi sur cinq est
supprimé plusieurs milliers de personnes
sont concernées
on est tous tombés
sur le cul ce qu'on a découvert vraiment
la situation financière de mecachrome
qui pour nous on savait n'était pas
bonne mais pas ce nouveau durement
touché par la crise des entreprises
régionales ont néanmoins maintenu leur
politique d'investissement pour innover
et ou pérenniser leur activité dans la
région
c'est le cas de caillots le fabricant de
colliers de serrage à romorantin des
fans de rivon bonjour vous êtes
directeur industriel et marketing de
l'entreprise
cailleau a connu un dépôt de bilan à la
crise la concurrence est pourtant
aujourd'hui le chiffre d'affaires
s'élève à 88 millions d'euros cette
année et en plus vous souhaitez recruter
40 personnes par an quel est votre
secret alors le secret c'est tout
d'abord l'innovation caillou à une
politique extrêmement forte en la
matière nous avons 95 ingénieurs et
techniciens qui travaillent
d'arrache-pied pour développer les
produits de l'avenir nous déposons entre
trois et cinq brevets par an et nous
avons plus 200 300 brevets actifs en
portefeuille à l'innovation était la clé
du succès pour l'industrie automobile
je le pense sincèrement l'innovation
permet d'avoir des produits
différenciants d'avoir des produits qui
apporte un plus à nos clients c'est ce
qui permet aujourd'hui de régénérer le
portefeuille produits de la société et
donc d'avoir toujours une longueur
d'avancé sur des concurrents qui sont
toujours à l'affût
[Musique]
les entreprises régionales de la filière
automobile bénéficie de l'accompagnement
de centre technologique de laboratoires
de recherche et de pôles de
compétitivité et la sto paul est un pôle
de compétitivité avec nous olivier gil
vous êtes le directeur
le milieu de l'automobile représente 75%
doit déboucher selon vous à l'industrie
automobile est elle une filière d'avenir
alors bien sûr parce que les
consommateurs continueront à utiliser
les amis pendant encore de nombreuses
années
c'est une filière innovante en
permanence toujours proposer de
meilleurs produits de des produits plus
économes des produits plus adaptés aux
défis de l'environnement notamment vous
devez sans cesse être en alerte pour né
pas à devenir obsolète dans le milieu de
l'automobile
tout à fait et c'est un des axes sur
lesquels travaillent en permanence de
veille sur donc les évolutions à venir
des marchés
le monde automobile est en constante
évolution les acteurs qui le composent
doivent constamment innover inventer
réinventer c'est ce qu'ont fait deux
jeunes passionnés créateur d'un concept
nouveau une agence automobile késako
amélie rigodanzo et isabelle racine vous
emmène à bh car ambiance start garantie
bh carré donc une concession automobile
mais pas seulement c'est surtout la
première société à avoir eu l'idée de
jouer les intermédiaires entre vendeurs
et acheteurs de véhicules d'occasion
elle est donc aux voitures ce que les
agences immobilières sont au logement
je regarde si le ciel de toit en fête a
été abîmée si les gens étaient fumeurs
ou non dans le véhicule
j'ai regardé le kilométrage en même
temps qu'ils à 95 milles kilomètres
je regarde si les tissus sont pas
minimes cuir et ensuite j'ai regardé les
papiers tout l'entretien de veto
l'acheteur repart avec une voiture
vérifier une garantie la carte grise et
des facilités de paiement
le vendeur lui se déleste des formalités
administratives et peut même garder son
véhicule jusqu'à la vente le vendeur ne
peut pas acheter tout petit son vécu la
plus simple peut-être besoin des fonds
donc on va faire une sorte de dépôt qui
s'appelle virtuel on va vérifier son
véhicule pendant une heure dans notre
atelier mécanique on va prendre des
photos du véhicule et dès qu'on aura un
client intéressé pour son véhicule alors
on l'appellera elle pourra revenir mais
entre temps il peut continuer aller au
travail et que son véhicule est utilisé
naturellement sa voiture
alors tu as regardé pour le capteur
l'idée est née en 2010 entre mathieu et
guillaume deux copains d'enfance qui ont
d'abord commencé par acheté et retapé
des mobylettes de la petite idée est
ensuite n'est la franchise n'a passé
devant 8 en limitant son passé très vite
en fait on s'est pas rendu compte qu'on
a grandi au fur et à mesure n'a pas
grandi d'un coup donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui maintenant comprend le
recul on se dit on a fait plein de
choses mais en même temps il y aller
étape par étape
donc j'estime que tout ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui on l'abat volet on le mérite
aujourd'hui bh car ces 50 agences en
france et 2 100 collaborateurs pour un
chiffre d'affaires de plusieurs millions
d'euros
quel que soit le secteur la filière
automobile est une filière d'avenir 14%
de la recherche et développement la
région est consacrée à l'automobile
cela crée beaucoup de capitaux et
beaucoup d'emplois qui sont que trop peu
pourvus
et pour la petite info sachez que le
centre val de loire et la cinquième
région de france en terme de recherche
et développement